hi I'm Sadashiva PI from science mission
today we have a doctor I go circle ow
professor of tuft University School of
Engineering with us dr. Sokolow has an
unique background in multiple branches
of natural science high energy physics
quantum field theory cosmology gravity
advanced materials self-assembly
microbiology microscopy nanotechnology
nano physics nano medicine mechanics at
micro and nano scale
I cannot economics looks like he has
done everything so he has over 150
peer-reviewed publications including
nature physical physical reviews nature
nanotechnology nature methods materials
today etcetera so he has a scientific
Citation Index of more than 5500 more
than 20 patents and patent applications
he has welcome to dr. sickle oh hello
thanks for joining science anchored
interest can you please tell us about
your background education and some of
the projects you are working on well
again could remind you how much time do
I have to do that maybe a few minutes
okay
so I think the broadness of the
background is defined by simply
political situations in the countryside
was brought up and then had to leave
because initially I was educated as a
high energy physicist quantum field
theory and that was really interesting
because it really answers the questions
fundamental questions so where the
universe come from what is actually we
build off and so on and after collapse
of Russian science after perestroika I
had
pretty much that I had only two choices
either to change my occupation or to
change country and I still liked physics
a lot and I decided let's try
so we emigrated to Canada where I found
first some applications of physics to
biology and medicine and I was really
fascinated that it's so much what
physicists could do there because in
some applications
looks like the developments around the
Stone Age saw some applications and some
developments are really stellar but some
are really weird of course whether there
are some explanations but why people
still prefer to do that simple
procedures but anyway so that it was
really interesting and then I simply
consider the University work as a sort
of exploring of unknown and everything
is interesting and particularly if it's
rewarding if it's by people recognition
I mean not in terms of citations or
something there this is the recognition
that you understand that you are doing
things which people need that's why
focus of the interest is in aging cancer
and recently we also looked at
cardiovascular diseases so that's pretty
much the major three problems humankind
have as I mean okay tell us about your
lab lab people students postdoc etcetera
mm-hmm I have the moment for PhD
students and the two postdocs one is on
leave and I think that's a very
reasonable size of the group because I
tried several times well it's pretty
much ups and down so it's very hard to
control because support of science in
this country is almost impossible to
plan and
there is a temptation to develop a
bigger group and so you have more or
less like less fluctuations but if I
have more than five eg students and
three postdocs what I found I'll really
spend a lot of time for administration
so pretty much I was like a hostage of
this group because I had to write more
and more grants to support them and it's
not fun because well the level of
support is such that writing grants is a
lot of time counterproductive but at the
same time I have to say that writing
when you do writing you better
understand something so that's that's
also what I'm trying to teach it is
postdocs and some students who actually
have natural ability to do good writing
and also to do I'll say mindful mindful
ranking we write something it's actually
kind of interesting because I think a
good writer have to have a sort of sort
of bipolar disease so we have to really
have two people on you one is who is
doing the writing and the other guy who
is criticizing you so that's the only
recipe how you can do meaningful writing
I think okay and how do you motivate
these people like I mean like research
goes ups and down there are some good
days bad days experiments don't work so
how do you keep them motivated make sure
that they work hard
yeah that's well technically I first I
think that they already at that level
most should be motivated themselves
because in academia when you work you
work for yourself
there are a lot secondly it's not really
motivation but rather help because the
first thing what I'm keep saying to to
students when they're ready that I so
many people in my career who are passed
through different stages of the career
they were initially students and then I
seen what happened a leader to them what
kind of careers in God and I see one
common denominator of all successful
people it's not really intellect or I
mean well kind of ability to solve
problems or pass tests it's not even how
you verbally communicate it is one thing
it's called resilience it's really how
you keep can keep conscious or can
tolerate down sand trailer and this is
the most important part that's what I'm
trying to tell people that they should
really consider failure is a very good
indicator because if you don't fail I
mean you cannot really learn anything
yeah so the only thing it's like you
have to go kind of up and up and do if
he's at a particular topic you'd have to
do like less and less and simple
mistakes yeah so the gradient is
important rather than just errors by
themselves mistakes himself okay and can
you please talk about some of the role
models or the mentors you had in your
career regretfully I do I can't really
say that I had a good mentor who could
guide me maybe because I had to really
change my occupation so many times so
many probably too but I would say that
in terms of motivating mentoring that
was Jeffrey Rosen he is a professor of
chemistry in University of Toronto in
Canada and it's simply the person who I
think was very natural a moderator he
has charisma and definitely it's one of
the people who would be very successful
if he decided to be a politician for
example because he definitely can
convince people to do something and feel
where they are doing something unique as
well
necessarily be very important to Cancun
some boring things yeah but still he
projected that can feeling Co component
C and this I think you're very important
or good my creation because if you think
that you'll do is very technical and
porridge pops out it will not be
successful okay you have like a like
there are some people were to enjoy
doing repetitive work but I don't think
it's really scholars okay and I know you
are busy with all the projects and all
those things so how do you balance your
work with your lifestyle like what are
your hobbies interests other than
research well I like hiking
from time to time and I also like to
join it because you can lack of time
jogging because when you hike it takes a
little time with your job is much faster
yeah but amount of relaxation that you
get is definitely way more money job and
I also like meditations ok I think
that's very close to how you do
experiments or you think about science
it's almost like for example when you
learn something you try to think what
you're doing but when you do something
you do it is very dangerous to think
it's almost like a feeling and it's the
same like you you'll drive bicycles so
you don't really think where to move
your steering wheel or when you walk
like how to move your lands so you
pretty much like just do that and then
that's what ideally be skill that
greatest students have to learn so they
have to develop the knowledge they are
so comfortable they don't think anymore
they feel and that's pretty much
I think wow I'm initation I think is
good because the feeling when you do
experiments is almost the same you
immerse in something and you don't
really think what you do and you just
kind of keep doing it and enjoy the
process and see something look for
something unusual okay
and coming back to your work so you had
a physicist and or what got you
interested in cells diseases yeah
looking because I am ingredient to
Canada in 1994 that was the year of
previous year was Ronald Reagan American
president who's something super duper
little American type of names of
projects things like super conductive to
Pro Collider or some kind that and
approximately test of energy physicists
were out of job but I had like negative
chances to find a job and so I pretty
much look around what I can also do and
I was like it to be introduced and hired
as a postdoc at the Department of
Microbiology in the University of
Toronto and simply roll some equations
about their bounce and they were say wow
you can really present some kind of
really scary math to describe our
bacteria so they hired me to do some
sensing work mostly sensing called
emails and that's the first time I was
introduced to this area area of biology
and later medicine analyst mayst
perception of how people treat you
around so I simply felt a much more
respect because we do some of physics
will say oh yes
olya versus our accomplice things but
it's much not working not really nobody
cares I mean Kira's but it's
kind of one of the interesting char
probably stands like 10th or 12th in the
line of priorities but when you speak
about medicine you immediately have some
resonance with people and it's a very
rewarding feeling it's almost like the
feeling that you do some volunteer in
the job to help people that's I think
what exactly motivates them and I looked
and I found why are all these
technologies that we have this days we
still don't understand what cancer is
still don't understand interaction of
cells one day block of arteries of blood
vessels and it's completely weird and we
don't understand aging aging cos are
really unusually if you look at science
fiction region is so brain changing
online changing so though it's you
hardly can find one or two normal
science fiction novels where humans
would be immortal or at least like leaf
extremely long because nobody even can
imagine what what it means so then
that's also like looking between the
even make sense to try to fix human body
maybe it's like much easier to transfer
our consciousness and something like a
machine it's also open question and
that's also very close to my lost
interest in economics because we hear
like I were in from Soviet even former
Soviet Union and by all my life there I
proved somebody theory and that theory
was purely chemical and it turned out is
wrong and of course it was very natural
for me as a scientist asked what was
wrong and I checked Adam Smith first guy
who actually initiated the science of
economics and I was really amazed
because the guy actually indicated was
wrong
there from the beginning it's simply
interest of individual people for all
these economic theories the
or with only maybe one exception quite
recent is called an Asian Theory ignore
interest of individuals but that's I'm
sure that that's where the whole
problems of modern economy is common a
common because people this thing the
interests of individual people they kind
of assumed that as soon as your work or
corporation your interests are 100%
aligned with corporation interests and
well that's what we develop also saw
Theory model which shows what happens if
it's not and it's kind of a lot of
interesting conclusions yeah so you have
done some work on AFM and cell biology
so can you please go ahead and present
your work on that yes AFM is atomic
force microscopy and I was lucky I was
introduced to this technology at the
time it was born by my PhD advisor and
at the time it was theory and it helped
me a lot to converge my interest with
medical area in particular biology I
mean microbiology because what happened
there my first microscope is I have like
a few slides and the presentations like
to explain it's like a finger and this
finger touching the surface and you get
information about the surfaces
topography almost the same like blind
person touches the surface and gets a
feeling how to look like and it can work
in liquids you can put your hand on the
water and or physiological solution so
we can really feel and see cells in
their physiological conditions why are
they alive that is why from the
beginning there was a really big
interest from medical area from
biomedical area in this microscopy but
at that time about 30 years ago that
time people didn't know well forces
work and that scale because what do you
do with your finger you touch you don't
really touch surface you touch something
which will pass your finger if you put
some cellphone on your hand or what Lu
will try to touch you will feel whatever
you have on your hand not the hand
itself of course you can push it like
harder and so on but still it is forces
what you feel that is why this
technology is called atomic force
microscopy atomic it's kind of a word
showing the ultimate limit or
sensitivity of this technique because it
can sense even atomic forces but the
problem was because people didn't know
this forces you get some recording by a
computer some profile of forces but what
it means people didn't know well and it
was a lot of artifacts simply produced
as a true surface of cells bacteria or
even molecules and as a result many
biomedical area or scientists from
biomedical area were very disappointed
in this technique in the beginning it
was even the same that in force
microscopy can produce whatever you like
and it was true because technically if
you don't know what you're measuring so
if you carefully as soon as like even I
remember one of my presentations in the
conference I showed a picture where have
some noise and this is a technique that
records something no matter like its
record force do you call this noise or
not it's simply your visual perception
and I see that bunch of scientists
trying to convince me that I had to put
a graduate students work hard for
several month to find one picture will
do quite better not this noisy but the
whole point was that this noise was the
information we want to analyze because
that was exactly the baby we're trying
to grow instead of just throwing it away
and
that's why I think main reason why for
30 years this is the only microscopy
that hasn't been used in for medical
areas yet there were some work done in
Europe by one of the founders of this
microscopy but again it's mostly using
sensors developed with the in force
microscopy rather than microscope in
itself then that's why and also after
graduation beautiful yeah for several
years in the Institute of neutrality and
metrologist stands for pretty much the
same like a local least naturalist due
to extenders it's how you do something
accurately and precisely that's why it
was my natural desire to make tillich
force microscopy as a repeatable as
quantitative as possible and this is
what is needed for medical area so it
should be independent on where
measurements who are done by whom which
AFM probe you use because probes are
different it's like really very sharp
needle which you can buy commercially
from different manufacturers and so on
as to know that's why cells were always
the interest this microscopy has
unprecedented resolution
it can give you x y&z like in all three
directions high resolution it can do
give you maps of physical properties of
surface of cells again with resolution
that no other technique can give you so
it was always on the table that this
mech microscopy could definitely produce
give us some knowledge which no other
techniques could give you okay can we
learn from your work like any present
your work so that we can learn about so
I have a presentation which I think I
also added some recent work not about
force microscopy but also about
nanoparticles and it relates to force
microscopy because here we can see with
a recent development in force microscopy
video we created two new imaging modes
in my lab and these one of the models
allows you to see surface coating called
nanoparticles and this is I think
crucial for what we call nano medicine
these days so this is pretty much the
presentation and I will so you see it
yeah uh-huh so on the background you see
a typical picture of a cell image by
atomic force microscope it's a 3d and
because what force microscope records
its position of let's say height at each
point or location of the servers and
it's recorded by a computer and can be
presented pretty much in any color any
type of presentation of digitally image
so nowadays it's McComas unlimited
possibilities so that's the outline of
my presentation I want to tell you about
ultra bright fluorescent nanoparticles
for cancer detection and drug delivery
and that's where again it'll be post
microscopy sleeky and second atomic
force microscopy is our recent work as
non-invasive method of detection of
cancer and particular shown how it works
on bladder cancer that's also power
recent work just published I think it's
not even officially published it's just
on online and this number two it's I
think could be the first clinical
application if it's adopted now for this
microscopy
by the way if you feel that something is
not clear so just just interrupt them
okay question so uh well first what is
nano its smallest like trivial these
days probably everybody can look at a
relative
this is Wikipedia slide showing that
Nano is something I don't do see one yes
yeah though it's something between
molecules small molecules and atoms and
large objects like well in this case it
said jeans but do support large you can
see them on do you like good magnifier
you don't really need a microscope for
that so some bacterial cells are some
dust particles if you go to desert
desert so you can get some particles on
the size of like several microns in air
human hair for example is about like 10
microns and one micron is 1000
nanometers so uh what is the problem of
an enema dicin these days nanoparticles
are really beautiful objects for
targeted drug delivery and cancer was
very natural choice because typically
cancer is treated with chemo therapeutic
drugs which are simply some toxins and
the only difference between these toxins
and any other toxin that this toxin is
more toxic for cancer cells than for
normal cells but still it is toxic to
normal cells and that is why there is a
big desire to make these deliver these
toxic drugs only to tumors instead of
just spreading to the entire organism
how it's done right now and that was on
the table for quite a while
picture here is from 2005 it's a number
of papers pretty much this
number of papers using different dick
describing different nanoparticles
delivery and here it's efficiency in
percent efficiency I mean how much you
for example you totally say one gram and
this is one at percent of that one gram
is delivered to actual tumor and this is
certain by years do your efficiency in
percent for for for three years and you
see that in median and actually look in
this there is no progress for the last
ten years so we try to think are to to
understand why I think again our
hypothesis is that it based on the same
issue that force microscopy faced before
people don't quite understand forces
forces acting at that scale between
nanoparticles and surrounding of the
organism which nanoparticles face and
white forces oh because we imagine that
you are this small nanoparticle you have
to really get sticky to only cancer
cells but you're in a very complex
environment and because of this very
lowly efficiency means that you stick
somewhere not in appropriate place but
stick means there is an attraction force
force that you attracted to something
which are not supposed to be attracted
as a result the efficiency is low now
how we try to understand with the help
of force microscopy so this is pretty
much our force microscope works there is
they have some small chip made of
silicon with a cantilever like this dish
a cantilever with a very sharp probe or
needle attached to the air ethics of
this handle this gently or continually
flexible it can go up and
and deflection of this can't be or is
detected by a laser light which is
deflected from the top and detected by
some photo detector ah let's see this
guy can you see it moving
no okay we gotta collect most of the
times yes M so let's think that that's
because I do see it on my screen okay
it's a problem sharing and but in any
case like if there is a bump and at the
same time this surface of a sample moves
left or right this bump would push this
needle up and the new Porsche the
cantilever so they can't you deflect up
and down and the angle of reflection of
laser light changes that's the basic
mechanism of detection of signal in
force microscopy so it's a deflection of
the cantilever and we can clear is like
a small spring the bigger detection the
bigger force linear proportionality
so what we are recently developed it is
an new mode of force microscopy by the
way this was it was kind of irony
because this mode we call this rincon
mode was commercialized almost
simultaneously with its publication so
University got a patent for this mode
faster then we produce a paper for
publication see the first time in my
career and I never heard about his
techniques so it was and this mode
allows you to see eight additional
channels almost like eight dimensions of
a service and one of this channel is the
height of the neck for example when
approved touches the surface it's
flexible and there are some molecules
coating the surface and then probe
disconnects from the surface Pro can go
up and down
when prob disconnects from the surface
it falls small neck from the surface
before it disconnects so one of the
channels is that we measure height on
this neck and the probe goes at one
point of the surface then it goes to
another point and so on and creating the
entire map of surface of the service so
the second channel is a biscuit biscuit
it's the size of the molecule size of
molecules which are covering the surface
because our probe pulls these molecules
out of the surface due to some
nonspecific interactions and what it
does it it was energy flicky clear whose
energy and uses some math we can restore
how much energy is lost and we can
restore the height of these molecules
this is her picture is an example of a
surface of a cell but what you see here
it's pretty much like big colors like
it's a more reddish it's a higher like
blue means is deeper so this is
distribution of molecular coating on
surface of cell of a cell and this is a
it's 2x2 microns so there is no other
technique which is capable of getting
such information so what you see is
presumably distributional glycocalyx so
it's like so fresh picture so we don't
even know exactly what it is but again
by the size its molecular coating can be
only molecular coating on the cell
surface we should talk like a chemist so
we use this technique to see molecule
coating surrounding nanoparticles
because remember I said that many
particles should speak only to terms but
somehow they stick everywhere else but
only like 1% and best wishes a tumour
and stick the chiller so coating so this
particles are coated probably not
sufficient
so coating can protect them from
sticking to everywhere like smoke kind
of a brush pushing away this particles
from everywhere but it's maybe not
enough and this is a picture of example
how what we see with this technology so
this is a picture simply on the left its
height image the brightest higher and
not on the right you see that it's a
coating and the coating it's not
continuous
you can see for example here you have
less brighter area which means depth
it's a deep kind of you even like no
coating at all and there is a pretty big
coat in here so that's a were always
better to differentiate particles by the
hackage of the molecular protein and see
do we have defects on the surface or not
and secondly but this is maybe a little
bit so and this is where we actually
stand right now we are now trying to see
the targeting of tumor using
nanoparticles which have different
molecular coating with and without
defects we kind of would like it to
develop some particles without defects
and some preliminary the experiments
already shop that they work very well
and to see the two more we develop
particles which we called ultra bright
they are substantially brighter than
quantum dots one of those are at this
point is small semiconductor crystals or
polymer particles also send a conductor
which are are very bright so compared to
classical quantum doors we have maybe 10
up to 800 times brighter and if you
compare to the very accurate if you
compare two so-called polymer dots which
are polymer sandokan
semiconductor
particles we have maybe like two times
higher but our particles are
silica-based
and quantum dots in the polymer or not
follow there are still resolve problem
of tacticity so you need a brightness of
fluorescence but it is weak for those
who might not necessarily know what it
is
fluorescence you use one light but in
Reverse you shine one light but the
surface particle shining back light of
different color why it's important you
always can put a filter and remove this
excitation light but only see the light
of different color which is coming from
particles and this is a huge advantage
because you can see very very small
sources of light it's almost like you
put some filter blinding light around
you see only like night dark not and you
see Pawn Stars steppers all the
particles which are producing light so
this is a technology which allows for
example to see tumors but for a surgeon
or for doctor who does that Gnostics
sadnesses you need to really see some
particular lesions or abnormality in the
organism and fluorescence works the best
for that so this is an example of
zebrafish in red maybe here it's a
little bit better so green and here a
particularly quite Isha's collection of
very bright spots where we have a lot of
particles and here in the red channel we
have a tumors
it's melanoma in oops sorry it's not at
all
it is cervical cancer human cervical
cancer introduced into zebrafish
and you can see a very nice
colocalization so our particles reach
those to your side and accumulator than
them so you can kind of looking at the
same position on fish now see that
particles to show this greenish
allocating around is not melanoma but
here
cerebral cancer sites so uh it's maybe
you can skip it why we need yeah that's
that's by the way one very important
part we also develop particles with the
help of also force microscopy where we
can see a good coating and it's
colorectal cancer this is a regular
column of mice these moms and this is a
healthy part and here you have tumors
developed and what we did here with
simpler means this come on with a
solution of our particles and wash them
away within 15 minutes we get very high
contrast so contrast we see glowing size
of tomorrow so if you kind of higher
resolution so you can see like a lot of
color coming from Timor and this dark
picture it means like healthy tissue the
mechanism of this targeting is not a
hundred percent here but obviously this
might be very helpful for detection of
small lesions children colonoscopy
because colonoscopy is a technique to
check if person may have some colon
cancer it's kind of a visual inspection
of column but small lesions can be
easily missed and this is the way where
it would be helpful for doctors also if
particles can accumulate there with
fluorescent dye because particles are
fluorescent because we charge them their
pores we charge them with your S&I but
can chart with you can load them with
and take cancer drugs and then it would
be an interesting delivery vehicle for
cancer treatment so that's that's where
our force microscopy and quite a recent
development helped us so that's maybe
like a little bit of why we think I
think that for the sake of time I can
Steve this is the interesting part about
cell that and a force microscopy that
you ritually can feel molecular coating
around cells picture here's schematics
of how they look like they have the cell
body which may be wrinkled and then with
some molecules surrounding cells pretty
much all our cells besides maybe a very
particular part of bacterial cells also
have this molecular code it's very
natural protection against invasion of
some bacteria viruses and if you try to
do regular force microscopy you don't
wanna see these molecules because they
are too soft
sharp probe would simply deform them
instead what do you do you can simply
put a sphere for example spherical probe
which are bigger you don't have that
high resolution but then when you start
to press this cell you start to press a
lot of these molecules and you start to
feel them and then that's where force
microscopy can help and we can
distinguish distribution of these
molecules and it turned out it's kind of
some math and this is an example of this
spherical probe and through some math we
can derive the number of these molecules
or cancer cells versus normal cells and
is what we are kind of tried to do now
when you see that cancer cells have
substantial different molecular coating
around them these are are nonspecific
molecules mostly molecules of
polysaccharides people don't know what
exactly the role of these
polysaccharides there were some work
they were thinking about that this
polysaccharides may help to avoid the
iWatch of immune system cancer cancer
cells are kind of hiding from the immune
system because if human systems see
cancer its doomed but somehow they try
to avoid it and there are like multiple
ways to do that and one of the ways
people think we produced too much of
this highly molecules around them but
also they found that it's not only that
it has this structure of coating
molecular coating cancer cells is much
more sophisticated kind of rougher than
coating core normal cells and that's
where we come towards direct imaging of
such cells and the idea again came from
exactly what I just said we do see
molecular coating all cancer cells to be
quite different from normal cells so how
to do that we found that difference in
the molecular coating own cells
extracted from human cervix how human
cervical cancer but when it came to
doctors just to ask do you have some
samples it really would be glad to to
analyze them they said why do you want
to look at cervical cancer in the United
States these cancers almost eradicated
it's mostly kind of still you can find
some more cases in South Texas but and
there is a strong center there
and the East Coast or we have we can
offer you much more interesting like a
quotation mark of course interesting
task its bladder cancer bladder cancer
the like different statistics gives you
a little bit different numbers like
third or fourth cancer responsible to
mortality it's a third for for man it's
less prevalent in women but what is
interesting about this cancer it is the
most expensive cancer to monitor and
treat a patient and it's also in terms
of suffering probably one of the worse
because the procedure right now as soon
as the cancer is identified you have to
be washed or even if it's treated you
have to be washed between three to six
months with a method clinical test which
is called us at dusk appear say Tosca P
is a really invasive methods it's like
Louise a video camera which put through
your Jeannie Talia so to examine
visually examine bladder surface of
bladder and it's not only painful during
procedure you have anesthesia but later
you can get pain wake up to one week
like what people told me
so it's something which people try
really to avoid but so it's painful
examination which you have to really do
for quite a while so there is definitely
people trying to find some methods which
would be a less invasive or maybe non
invasive at all and what we try to do it
turned out which actually wasn't used to
me that our urine contains cells cells
exfoliated from the surface of blood or
and other parts when we do urination we
expel some cells
and to collect this cells it's quite
easy and hospitals already do that but
what they do so far they simply examine
these cells under optical microscope and
of course optical microscopy has a very
limited resolution and mystic it's
definitely not efficient for accurate
and not really treated at the serious
alternative to sight escaping so of
course like what we try to do is to
apply our methods to scan these cells
and this what we urge that's pretty much
like I said that our new reading mode
allows the image multiple channels
simultaneously this is just again a
picture surface of cell this is melanoma
sunshine this is a light brightest
higher and there are multiple channels
like energy losses channels are this
height pooling of neck and this
connection business showing a
distribution of molecules on the surface
or such cell so you can see there's
quite wealth of information all of that
is not a qualitative picture all of them
are really in nanometers or in kill
electron volts
so all them are independent or well at
least we check it and within a broad
range of imaging parameters they are
independent on the type becomes the way
you do the experiments we do the imaging
and this is super important because it
has to be repeated so what do we need
well we have 43 healthy patients and
actually healthy it's not a good war
because more than half think you know
more than 2/3 of these people had
already cancer before bladder cancer
before and they're in remission right
now they don't have active games
and 22 actually right now we have
already 25 cancer patients
which have active cancer and that was
defined by simple clinical dissection so
they were taken pieces of tumor for from
their blood ER and after histology it
was clinically identified that those
guys have cancer so and this kind of
escaped some technicalities so
essentially we scanned the surface of
these cells and by some historical
reason we looked only at one channel
adhesion channel not always eight
channels additional that I said it's
simply adhesion channels so because we
started collecting these samples at that
time we didn't have our new mode as yet
so we keep collecting but we can at this
moment have enough statistics only for
the extra channel of course Hyde but
Hyde we saw that hiding which actually
doesn't give you very good information
TV channel in the US and previously
that's what I said about it within
cervical cells cancer normal cell
carcinoma we did also the question of if
cancer can be treated as care chaotic
behavior or not
simply if doctors can look at cross
sections cross sections of tumors this
is almost I would say first-year medical
students you can easily identify tumors
because it looks like calorie that was a
thought that on the level of cells
cancer also will be chaotic but what he
found we looked at this model of
cervical cancers from immortal
immortalized cells we considered the
pre-cancers towards cancers
and we found that it's a mistake of
immortal has already changed and we
analyze so called fractal dimension
fractals are it's a geometry property of
a geometry which typically occur during
some coding processes and that's where
why we looked at this and try to
understand do we see some fractal
behavior and I really don't have that
slide here so what actually found that
cancer is not cows it's not fractal it's
only we observe this pure frack cow only
at the stage between transition between
immortal to cancer immortal you can
think about this it's a benign tumor
it's really growing part it's really not
dangerous as yet but cancerous malignant
it's like where you can get some
invasiveness so that we don't quite
understand why it happens so definitely
we need to find some biochemical way and
why it's needed why you'll say like oh
here's some substance but because as
soon as we know if it's really due to
some coding behavior in biochemical
reactions chaos is typically identified
through I mean it can be influenced
through some specific points of
bifurcation so this can be chain of
chemical reactions and in that chain
there are some points which are
substantially more important than others
to produce coding behavior so if you
find try to find those points we can
definitely influence this behavior and
who knows maybe maybe cancer it's of
course like highly speculative but it is
a software which people haven't really
thought before so it might be a new way
to attack on cancer
and the last thing is when you see
different images of course it's always
the question like can you really
identify using for example some machine
learning Google Facebook now can easily
identify our faces even the iPad iPhone
but can you really do something similar
to this images potentially probably yes
but it would bring us to the problem of
so-called Big Data one of the problem of
big data you need a big database to
train your machine learning algorithm to
identify to teach this algorithm who is
who and we don't have that luxury we
have already look 4543
normal and 25 cancer patients and that
took us like more than 5 years because
of like when you do something new you
don't have money for that I mean that's
that's quite regretfully it's very hard
to get support for something truly new
so that's why it was a pure enthusiasm
and took like quite a lot of time so we
said if you really treat this image as a
picture we would need many many
thousands of patients before we actually
can make the training so that was that
end so what we did and it's known of in
this type of problems which were free
news number of information per picture
so instead of using the picture sooner
reduces two numbers of calls so called
surface parameters for example like
roughness directionality a fractal
properties and so on those parameters
would people use to characterize surface
in engineering it's a long list of
approximate like forty parameters that's
what we did and then we tried different
tests including neural network neural
network actually it was not very good
because it's so easy to over
trained to produce some kind of false
results and so that's it's built so
called learning trees
well new trees you have like say like
one parameter is you some threshold and
say that below this threshold you have
like good indication that is cancerous
below it's a healthy and so on and you
kind of try to build some sort of a tree
which at the top in Definity that this
is cancer this is normal this is cancer
normal and so on and there are like
different methods it would definitely be
separate lecture about how this methods
work and why we did it
but what we need of accuracy so this is
just a picture showing that some
parameters are more important so the
bigger bar is the more important
parameter for segregation between cancer
normal and you see the height is could
have like Oh parameters almost good but
in adhesion you are kind of very
pronounced number of parameters which
are telling us who this is what is not
and it's some statistics using once
though and for like for those who don't
really know statistics it's just look at
this graph its accuracy it's about
eighty percent this is number of surface
parameter we take into account and you
see that around ten it's already like
good so we need ten surface parameters
to do prediction if you use five cells
because you can combine different cells
together to make a better prediction
you're the one cell it's like in deeper
level it's eighty percent accuracy it's
still it's one cell and person can make
a mistake when analyzing one cell it's
definitely more much safer when you do
analysis of five cells and when you look
at it you already have more than ninety
percent to be precise it's 94 percent
accuracy and if you compare with the
presently existing method
it's around like 80% what we have so of
course like you also have to say like
how significant this difference because
you have a very limited number of people
you analyze there is a way how you
unambiguously answer that question
it's called statistical significance and
we stopped our analysis where our
enthusiasm and money actually run away
and she was no money from the beginning
in English so just mostly enthusiasm and
we said we had to publish it now it's
exactly the point where we reach the
number of people where we do have
statistical significance our method as
it is already statistically
significantly better than this invasive
site tasks okay so that's by the way
this is also kind of important you
always can't check if your machine
learning method is good or not in terms
of overtraining because if you do like
you train train train and train it gets
better better and better but only for
that database that you do the training
if you choose something new your method
can fail and that is the biggest problem
of neural networks that's why we kind of
step away from it but how to check do
you have our training or not you take
your database or in which you have this
service parameters for each person and
clinical diagnosis cancer healthy cancer
healthy and then instead of cancer
healthy you put a flip a coin 50/50 you
randomize it so randomized Magnus's and
then you run the same procedure develop
your algorithm to check its accuracy and
what we so our accuracy was 54% before
it's like was 94 this is like five cells
so obviously we do have pretty much what
we expect close to 50% so we don't have
any overtraining in our algorithm that
that's that's important
so that's pretty much it so that's where
I think the most exciting developments
we really want to produce something with
was microscopy which might be directly
applicable to real life to medical area
of course I removed a lot of technical
details showing that we do have a lot of
verifications that our method is
independent on the way we do analysis we
do the imaging so it is truly robust so
the paper of about this last results
will be published in Proceedings of the
National Academy of Sciences and the
papers I think like three maybe like
four pages long and I think there are
more than like 30 pages of supplementary
materials showing exactly like what I
said we do have a very reliable method
so it's really quantitative and I hope
that we can get money from National
Institute of Health to do the final
study polishing the methods to answer
one more question
can we really distinguish not only
presence of cancer by the stage of
development of cancer because that's
what doctors need a lot because it would
define the way they prescribe the
treatment and this is important for for
it's a life-saving decision so that's
that's pretty much it and like if you
have any questions yeah
and share it I have one like we almost
out of time just I want not sure like
how long does it take for the AFM rather
than the regular screaming and all those
things they do like what is the time
like if you get the samples today how
does it happen within a day like what is
the time period very good question
that's one of the reasons why we develop
this new mode
because the previous standard relatively
standard method we started it was
painfully slow for example for
previously for one cell it took 1.5
hours to get a picture one cell in these
five cells with new method we have tests
done within one and a half hours the
whole test incredible we are working now
and we do have already it's developed
but not really data as yet from patients
we do have the tests even four times
faster so within one hour we can get the
answer and that's what typically doctor
said will be competitive because right
now they do not some alternative tests
using muslin biomarkers which are not as
accurate but it's required to know like
one hour that's that's requirement the
other question is this is the last one
so do you think the surface like you
have a different polysaccharides on the
surface with the cancer and as it
progresses and can you catch it using
AFM the particular type of all
cigarettes probably no although in
principle yes but you need to really
touch some sensitive molecules to the
AFM probe and it might be a little bit
of clinically difficult because you can
contaminate the probe so for example
another question would be like how long
you pro because your touch surface you
can continue grow for how long our probe
would last in our case is we ezel will
last like more than hundred cells with
no no with no changes and we do
precondition encode the probe a little
bit so you need to touch several times
so it creates very repeated a repeatable
structure so answering a question about
type of polysaccharides we do have kind
of research type of methods but such
probe would be contaminated too fast to
be a clinically clickable but
technically I would say that is probably
better to use some
nanoparticles or some more classical
methods essentially such--such
methodology exists is called lay comics
where people try to analyze coding cons
cell surface and see like your type of
polysaccharides they can but you need a
lot of cell phone that's all at this
point
okay thank you so much I really
appreciate your time I it was very nice
like I'm not a physicist I'm a biology
so I learned a lot from what you have
said today and I certainly wish you good
luck in your future work and if you
think there is something different
something new you can always get back to
us we can have another one sometime
thank you so much and again I don't know
how you do that but if you any questions
or we were to answer them so I put it on
Facebook LinkedIn everywhere so if at
all I give you a email to if anybody has
any questions they can directly contact
you super thank you very much